In the earlier description of data structures, we mentioned two terms that we
have not yet talked about, interrupts and signals.
Let's take a moment now to explain these concepts in a little more detail.
Interrupts are events that are generated externally to a CPU
by components that are other than the CPU where the interrupt is delivered.
Interrupts represent, basically,
some type of notification to the CPU that some external event has occurred.
This can be from I/O devices like a network device delivering an interrupt that
a network packet arrived or
from timers notifying the CPU that a timeout has occurred or from other CPUs.
Which particular interrupts can occur on a given platform depends on
the specific configuration of the platform,
like the types of devices that it has, for instance.
Or the details about the hardware architecture and similar features.
Another important characteristic about interrupts is they appear asynchronously.
That's to say that they're not in the direct response to
some specific action that's taking place on the CPU.
Signals, on the other hand, are events that are triggered basically by
the software that's running on the CPU.
They're either for
real generated by software, sort of like software interrupt, or the CPU hardware
itself triggers certain events that are basically interpreted as signals.
Which signals can occur on a given platform depends very much on
the operating system.
So two identical platforms will have the same interrupts, but if
they're running a different operating system they will have different signals.
Unlike hardware interrupts,
signals can appear both synchronously and asynchronously.
By synchronous here we mean that they occur in response to
a specific action that took place on the CPU, and
in response to that action, a synchronous signal is generated.
For instance if a process is trying to touch memory that has
not been allocated to it, then this will result in a synchronous signal.
There's some aspects of interrupts and signals that are similar.
Both interrupts and signals have a unique identifier.
And its value will depend either on the hardware in the case of interrupts.
Or on the operating system in the case of signals.
Both interrupts and signals can be masked.
For this, we use either a per CPU mask for the interrupt.
Or a per process mask for the signals to disable or
to suspend the notification that an interrupt or a signal is delivering.
The interrupt mask is associated with a CPU because interrupts are delivered to
the CPU as a whole.
Whereas the signal mask is associated with a process,
because signals are delivered to individual processes.
If the mask indicates that the signal, or the interrupt,
is enabled, then that will result in invoking the corresponding handler.
The interrupt handlers are specified for
the entire system by the operating system.
For the signal handlers however, the operating system allows processes to
specify their per process handling operations